We're crushing our coolest
videos into bite-sized pieces
for your inspiration and entertainment.
I'm Grant Thompson,
and this is King of Random Rewind.
10. VORTEX FOUNTAIN
9. NINJA TURTLE SLIME
8. MINI BBQ GRILL
7. INFINITY TUNNEL
6. CUSTOM FIREPLACE
5. NINJA BALLS
4. LASER LIGHT SHOW
3. MAGIC SAND
2. NORTHERN LIGHTS LAMP
1. ARC REACTOR LAMP
Hey guys, Grant here.
Hope you enjoyed this compilation.
If you'd like to see the full
tutorials for these videos,
we've got links down
in the description.
If you'd like to see
another compilation,
click the box up there
And if you're not already subscribed,
go ahead and click the bomb.
We'll see in the next video.
Talk to you then.